[Music]
breaking news this monday night the
kremlin calls the troops into eastern
ukraine
the new orders from russia's president
in two rebel regions he now recognizes
as independent vital vote mps debate the
validity of invoking the emergencies act
why is the prime minister using this
this is something that required extra
tools deadly confrontation a black man
he's very kind and
humble person killed by calgary police
the police are in an almost no-win
situation and reunited and it feels so
good this means the world to me
australia's border reopens to fully
vaccinated tourists
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with breaking news on the
crisis over ukraine russian president
vladimir putin has ordered a so-called
peacekeeping operation in eastern
ukraine's two breakaway regions the
dramatic escalation follows putin's
address to the nation where he
recognized donesk and lahansk as
independent states the move is stoking
fears putin is pushing forward on
invading ukraine which could spark a
military response from the west jackson
prosco has tonight's top story
with the stroke of a pen vladimir putin
launched a dramatic escalation in
ukraine recognizing two pro-russian
regions as independent giving leeway for
russian troops to cross onto ukrainian
soil under the guise of peacekeeping
the formalities came after a televised
airing of grievances by the russian
president in which he lamented the end
of the soviet union suggested ukraine is
run by a western puppet regime
and baselessly claimed keeve could soon
develop its own nuclear weapons to
target russia
russia has a right to take
countermeasures to enhance our own
security and that's how we plan to act
he said
international reaction was swift and
sharp this is plainly in breach of
international law there's a sense putin
is doing everything he can to find a
reason for war
heavy shelling continued in the disputed
donbass region along with bombings the
kremlin blames it all on ukraine
ukraine insists it's trying to avoid
getting drawn into a fight even as
several of its soldiers were killed and
wounded
they are always ready to provoke us
provoke us more and thus blame us for
their actions said this soldier on the
front lines
the u.s and nato are more convinced than
ever that a bloody invasion is coming
american intelligence claims russia has
plans to execute and imprison ukrainians
who support democracy this will not
simply be some conventional war between
two armies it will be a war waged by
russia on the ukrainian people to
repress them to crush them to harm them
far from de-escalation russia's latest
act has provoked sanctions and likely
killed off chances at a diplomatic
solution
vladimir putin has redrawn the map and
changed the game
putin's announcement today touched off a
flurry of calls between western leaders
they're trying to coordinate sanctions
and other retaliatory measures against
the russians announcements about that
will roll out heavily tomorrow we should
also point out that they haven't given
up on their basic calculus that putin
may still be planning a full-fledged
invasion of ukraine that's something
they're still deeply worried about
tonight colleen
jackson frosco in washington thanks
jackson
the ukrainian city of la viv is now a de
facto safe haven for citizens as well as
canadian and u.s diplomats who've been
relocated there la viv is about an
hour's drive from poland on the west
side of ukraine and opposite the
disputed donetsk and luhansk regions la
viv is where we find our crystal command
sing tonight crystal what is the mood
like there on the ground right now
colleen on the drive into levi the
majority of highway billboards either
featured an ad for the ukrainian
military or had three numbers scrawled
across them four five zero that's
military code for it's okay or all is
calm and that's the message ukrainian
leaders have been trying to spread as
tension with russia ramps up
the kremlin says it's not interested in
starting a war in ukraine but people
here are skeptical of russia's word
still fear has not seized this city in
the west near the polish border very
safe city levies mayor tells global news
a lot of effort has gone into planning
water can be provided with all
electricity should the utility be
targeted medicines have been stockpiled
along with blood supplies
the mayor draws on the city's legendary
lions the story goes they used to roam
the nearby woods and to this day
act as protectors
all
citizens in ukraine
must
be lions strong clients together we must
send
russian births
to
them
protection in ukraine is key as is faith
in such challenging times
chaplain mahalo dukkha says his job now
is to listen and be supportive of all
soldiers and families
there are not only christians in our
army but there are muslims and pagans as
well
each of them has faith in their heart
each of them hopes on protection from
their god
at a nearby pub the ukrainian canadian
owner says the more immediate danger is
the hit to the economy every country is
telling people don't go to ukraine
everybody's telling you to evacuate
cranes so we're going to have we're
under a serious problem this summer if
if the troops are there not invading and
everybody's not coming canadian american
british even dutch embassies have set up
shop in this city it is large and it's
bustling and while there is an
undercurrent of concern
it's not crippling this country or the
spirit of the people
colleen
crystal gomezing in ukraine crystal
thank you
turning to ottawa now the downtown core
remains quiet but it's hardly back to
normal in the nation's capital a
significant portion of ottawa's city
center is under lockdown after a
multi-day effort to remove protesters
and there are still questions about
whether the emergencies act was
necessary to clear this and other
protest sites in the country the prime
minister addressed the issue today
this state of emergency is not over
there continues to be real concerns
about the coming days
and mps have just finished voting on
whether to uphold or reject the
emergencies act the results are in and
the government has won the day our chief
political correspondent david aiken
joins us from ottawa and david the
events over the weekend changed the tone
of the debate
well colleen opponents of the decision
to invoke the federal emergency act had
been saying all along that it was never
needed conservative and block quebecois
mps pointed to the fact that border
blockades were cleared without the
federal emergencies act and now that the
ottawa occupation has been cleared and
the capitol's downtown secured they
renewed their objections to the prime
minister's decision to invoke the
emergencies act so using the tactic of a
schoolyard bully he has decided to
implement the emergencies act so that he
can control manipulate dictate it's the
equivalent of awakening the kraken a
legislative leviathan that should only
be broken when in the most dire
situations i don't believe that the
government has met the test but the
prime minister insisted it was still
necessary noting that many of the
parliament hill trucks are now camped
nearby ready to return indeed this video
shot by global news monday afternoon at
a farm about halfway between montreal
and ottawa there were about 125 vehicles
many of which had been on parliament
hill these last few weeks and they're
now camped about a hundred kilometers
from ottawa on a private farm across
from a truck stop supplying them with
fuel food and supplies when the
situation is still
of people
pre-positioning people
being out there indicating that they are
ready
to blockade to continue their illegal
occupations to disrupt canadians lives
we feel that this measure
needs to remain in place it's a minority
government of course so the liberals
looked to the new democrats to support
them on this issue
and that's how the vote played out
liberals in the ndp voted to confirm the
emergencies act conservatives in the bq
voted against but that is not the end
the senate now begins debate on the very
same issue and it will vote later this
week and if the vote fails there then
that's it the powers in the emergency
act would be immediately revoked colleen
david aiken in ottawa david thank you
deputy prime minister christian freeland
is attempting to set the record straight
about whose financial accounts have been
frozen in connection with the protests
freelance says the only people targeted
are protest organizers leaders and
people whose trucks were part of
occupations or blockades
anyone who
is concerned that their accounts may
have been frozen because of their
participation in these illegal blockades
and occupation
the way to get your account unfrozen
is to stop being part of the blockade
the rcmp has also issued a statement
saying it has not shared any information
about donors with financial institutions
concerns over the police handling of the
nova scotia mass shooting spree have not
faded nearly two years after the deadly
13-hour attack 22 people were killed by
a man disguised as an rcmp officer a
long-awaited public inquiry begins
tomorrow but as ross lord reports there
are concerns many of the outstanding
questions may never be answered
no one expects the mass casualty
commission to make sense of the horrific
events that took place nearly two years
ago but the public inquiry is mandated
to find out more about what led to the
massacre that started in close knit
porter pick and why it wasn't stopped
sooner public inquiries are
forward-looking and so it's really
important that we do work together
to
learn what we can from from this
terrible experience
the commission of inquiry has already
been investigating for more than a year
mostly behind closed doors spending
millions of dollars gathering and
analyzing information establishing a
foundation of facts before hearing from
witnesses about what they saw and what
they know
commissioners must also examine how the
gunman eluded the rcmp for 13 hours
claiming even more victims along the way
before an officer killed him at a gas
station 100 kilometers away from where
the murders began
the gunman's denture business was left
behind seen by nova scotians as a
perverse reminder of his sadistic
actions those symbols have been removed
along with the entire clinic
and communities that suffered most have
built memorials to the victims but
victims families and others shaken to
their core are still looking for answers
could it have been prevented are there
things that can be done so that
something like this doesn't ever happen
again in the future
another key challenge trusting the
process families were forced to lobby in
the streets before the federal and nova
scotia governments agreed to a full
public inquiry instead of a watered-down
version family lawyers say there's
secrecy surrounding witness lists and
whether they can question witnesses
directly during their testimony i think
that there it's more along the lines of
confusion and disappointment about a
process that doesn't appear to be
unfolding in a way that will allow them
to participate
in the way that they feel that they need
the commission says it's still
finalizing some processes but insists it
will be as open as possible public
hearings are scheduled to continue until
the end of may with a final report due
by november
ross lord global news halifax
calgary police under scrutiny coming up
the demand for answers after officers
shoot and kill a black man
calgary's sudanese community is
demanding answers after a man believed
to be experiencing a mental health
crisis was killed by police police say
la jortoul was armed with a weapon and
assaulted someone allegedly but friends
say he was in crisis and needed help
heather yorick's west has more and a
warning some of the images may be
disturbing
members of calgary's south sudanese
community say lachortul was a respected
man who called canada home for nearly 20
years he's very kind and
humble person
very intelligent man tule died saturday
after he was shot by police surveillance
video captured by a nearby business
shows newell approaching police with
what appears to be a weapon he also
appears to strike a police dog the
police were in a in a
almost no win situation
the the individual
was
threatening them he had a weapon
and he was advancing towards them police
have not said what kind of weapon tool
was holding witnesses say it appeared to
be a stick or a pipe friends say he had
a limp and often walked with some kind
of cane
he was also a former child soldier
before coming to canada as a refugee
friends believe he suffered a mental
health crisis before he died we're
looking for the police to protect us
here we are looking for safety here many
people have come here for safety left
with the war-torn country sudan to come
here and get a better life the use of
deadly force in calgary comes at a time
when black indigenous and other
racialized communities have questioned
whether the police response to illegal
protests in kuts alberta ottawa and
windsor ontario would have been the same
if protesters there had not been
primarily white they were able to
de-escalate folks who literally came
there for the sole purpose of
overthrowing the governments really the
only thing i can see here is that once
black guy now there's a couple white
dudes i can tell you that if there was
anybody who was attacking police
officers with a weapon acousts
at in ottawa or in uh at windsor you'd
get the same pretty much the same result
that happened here alberta's police
watchdog is now investigating heather
yorick's west global news calgary
quebec is using more pandemic
restrictions today the province lifted
capacity limits for visitors at private
seniors homes and retail stores
conferences public events and
programming at recreation centers can
also resume
up to 500 people are now allowed at
places of worship and funerals and they
no longer need a vaccine passport movie
theaters and indoor events like hockey
games can operate at half capacity with
passport checks
also today newfoundland and labrador is
dropping some public health restrictions
including all limits for retail stores
restaurants gyms fitness studios and
faith-based ceremonies can operate at 75
percent capacity
still ahead england prepares to ditch
coveted restrictions why the united
kingdom is divided on the new strategy
northern europe has been battered by
another wicked storm the third in less
than a week
storm franklin has killed at least two
more people disrupted travel and
prompted hundreds of flood alerts fierce
winds nearing 140 kilometers an hour
whipped up huge waves across the uk
slamming into coastal communities that
are still recovering from last week's
hurricane force winds
those same communities are preparing to
ease cobit 19 restrictions this week
england has an infection rate more than
twice that of canada but starting
thursday we'll remove all remaining
pandemic rules including the legal
obligation to self-isolate after testing
positive prime minister boris johnson's
plan for england has the other uk nation
saying not so fast redmond shannon
reports
behind the walls of windsor castle the
queen is still self-isolating with what
are described as mild covert 19 symptoms
look forward to seeing her back in
action very soon i hope she's going to
stay well but from thursday the monarch
won't face a police fine if she does
venture outside restrictions pose a
heavy toll on our economy
our society our mental well-being and on
the life chances of our children and we
do not need to pay that cost any longer
with infections and especially deaths
falling prime minister boris johnson is
ending the last of england's legal
restrictions
people who test positive will no longer
be obligated to isolate contact tracing
and support payments will both end and
from april free rapid tests will no
longer be available people in the uk
don't actually realize how extensive our
testing network has been and how
fortunate they have been to have access
to freely available testing a variety of
forms british canadian professor linda
bald says as countries move in this
direction it should ideally mark a new
era of personal responsibility for
seasonal diseases british stiff upper
lip of wandering to the office when
you're coughing and seizing i really
think we need to move away from that of
course the uk is more than just england
throughout the pandemic johnson has
frustrated the other three nations with
his more libertarian leanings we are
responsible for public health decisions
in our own countries but it's the
treasury who makes the funding decisions
and they seem to be only triggered by
the decisions boris johnson makes for
england the announcement from boris
johnson comes as he remains under a
police investigation for breaking his
own pandemic rules
colleen
redmond shannon in london redmond thank
you
new zealand's prime minister says
pandemic restrictions will ease when the
country is well beyond the peak of the
omicron wave which is expected to be mid
to late march
we all want to go back to the way that
life was and we will i suspect sooner
than you think
but when that happens
it will be because easing restrictions
won't compromise the lives of thousands
of people
not because you demanded it
hundreds of people are occupying the
lawns of parliament demanding an end to
restrictions new zealand has had some of
the strictest measures over the course
of the pandemic it's also had relatively
low infection rates and fewer than 60
covet 19 related deaths
back down under the heartwarming
reunions as australia opens its doors to
the world next
nearly two years after shutting out most
tourists due to the pandemic australia
fully reopened its borders to vaccinated
international travelers today of course
that's great news for anyone yearning to
see the sights of the land down under
but as mike armstrong reports for many
who've waited years to see loved ones
it's so much more
for most of the last two years the
international arrivals at sydney airport
felt like a ghost town it didn't today
it was one reunion after another
this couple hadn't seen each other since
before the pandemic began they're now
going to be married in three days it's
surreal i don't know i lose my mind
right now how does it feel to see you
again so good so good it's been so it's
been way too long
this was qantas first international
landing australia's national carrier has
154 flights this week a year ago this
week it had zero
country's reopening is making for some
very happy grandparents and
grandchildren so excited because i
haven't seen them for two years
and what are you guys what are you most
looking forward to now you're in
australia to spend time with them
australia's coveted lockdown was one of
the tightest of any democracy
australians started calling themselves
fortress australia the borders were
closed for 704 days the first day he
could canadian peter bayless went back
my parents live here so i haven't been
able to visit
for
just since just before covered so i'm
coming back for a family visit
now tourism experts say in the coming
months numbers will still be a fraction
of what they were pre-pandemic 30 to 50
percent but reopening is a step in the
right direction and on this day it meant
some pretty big smiles
albeit still behind masks
like global news
ah travel and that is global national
for this monday i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is the vancouver
skyline there are beautiful spots all
over canada please email yours to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back tomorrow have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you